ladies and gentlemen
it's the tech billionaire Deathmatch you
all haven't been waiting for
no seriously they are planning to fight
in one corner Twitter owner
then the other meta CEO
Mark Zuckerberg
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so yes this is funny but it's also
getting kind of serious last week Elon
Musk tweeted that he'd be up for a cage
fight with Mark Zuckerberg Zuckerberg
said send me location
musk said Vegas octagon Dana White the
president of the UFC told the Wall
Street Journal that he has spoken to
both Zuckerberg and musk about a
Face-Off they are both dead serious
white said
and now here we are but this fight is
much deeper than two big egoed
billionaires
history of the tech industry has been
about companies fighting over us the
users and our dollars oh and yes
different ideologies this fight is no
different
except well the possibility of a real
celebrity death match
so allow me ow me to explain what's real
and how it's indicative of this new
emerging Tech Battlefield
with the help of these guys custom
action figures may not precisely
replicate the likeness of the real
individuals let's look at the history of
this fight musk and Zuckerberg have
actually partnered in the past
in 2016 musk's SpaceX was supposed to
take Facebook's internet satellites up
to orbit until
at the time Zuckerberg said he was
deeply disappointed things really blew
up in 2018 though when it was revealed
at Cambridge analytica had Acquired and
used personal data from Facebook users
musk's Tesla and SpaceX deleted their
company Facebook pages and musk tweeted
it's not a political statement and I
didn't do this because someone dared me
to do it just don't like Facebook gives
me the willies sorry and again in 2022
he tweeted something similar Facebook
gives me the willies that was just a few
weeks before musk initiated an
acquisition of Twitter which officially
put these two up against each other as
competing social media CEOs musk said he
wanted Twitter to be an inclusive arena
for free speech he specifically taught
talked about political neutrality
something he didn't think that was found
in other social networks my
understanding is that Zuckerberg spent a
400 million dollars in the last election
normally in a get out the boat campaign
but really fundamentally in support of
Democrats is that accurate or not
accurate that is accurate does that
sound unbiased to you a meta spoke
2020 which said that these partisan
claims were false meanwhile musk has
been courting more folks from the right
including Tucker Carlson himself so yes
there's differing ideology but also
users
and money in 2022 Twitter reported an
estimated 238 million daily active users
meta's Facebook Instagram and WhatsApp
have 3 billion daily active users and a
far bigger ad business
but musk's takeover of Twitter has
pushed meta to build a Twitter
competitor reported to be called threads
it's said to be a text-based social
network like Twitter with integration
with Instagram in an internal meeting at
meta a top Zuckerberg Lieutenant said he
had heard from public figures who wanted
a sanely run platform that's what
actually prompted well
sure these guys are very public about
their rivalry but it's also
representative of the broader State of
Affairs right now in big Tech it used to
be that companies were Frenemies now
they just seem to be enemies just look
at this fight chart yes you have Twitter
and meta then Zuckerberg has been open
about his beef with Apple CEO Tim Cook
Apple has limited how much data Facebook
and other apps can collect on iPhones
and iPads and the two now compete on
mixed reality headsets then Google and
Microsoft are now in an AI battle
building on its existing Cloud fight
Google has even filed a complaint with
the Federal Trade Commission accusing
Microsoft of anti-competitive cloud
practices and then there's Amazon which
competes with Microsoft and Google on
cloud services too and then you've now
got open AI which Elon also has beef
with and competes with Google
yeah we're gonna need some more action
figures so who is gonna win in this
round
well Zuck clearly seems to have the
upper hand with his Jujitsu training and
a far bigger more prospering social
media Empire
but musk claims to have a move called
The Walrus where he just lies on top of
his opponent
or hey maybe these billionaires just go
in a totally different direction
[Music]
yeah I doubt it
why not just go get some sweet baby rays
sure wanna come on my private plane we
can eat it there okay